what's your outlining process
i will outline
to like
of the way there i will outline as much
as i feel like i can
um before i actually start writing
um
i find it personally very difficult
to
to do it any other way
um i do think there is a lot of value in
sort of again exploring and having that
sort of creativity but to me a lot of
that is the outlining and i think also
the reality is even if you outline
something like
99 of the way done
when you actually write it that won't be
what it'll be anyway
it's a it's a road map that
that will change
it just is what it is
um
at least
the way i do it
um
i think that also in addition to that
it's really important to know
like as much as you can
about
the characters and the themes and the
ideas that you want to explore before
again before i start writing writing i
do do a lot of exploring of these things
in a much more sort of nebulous way
um trying to think of like what else i
don't it doesn't really matter to me if
the outline's in order
i'll just outline the chunks of it that
i understand
i personally and again this is this is
the hard thing about this because i do
think everyone is different
to me
to me a lot of the sort of outlining is
very sort of mathematical
and it's like knowing like okay
like
there has to be
there will be this many scenes
and like and these are you know
where the big
you know the very large beats happen the
midpoint and the act ii climax and the
inciting incident those sort of things
and then if you can start filling in
like literally even i guess this is
where like note cards come from for some
people i don't use note cards
but i'll have like an equivalent on like
the computer where i just start like
filling in
like
i know
i like these scenes and i know this
should happen about here because i'm
trying to get to this big moment here
and now i feel like okay but this is
kind of empty
like
in the sort of like whatever the
the 30 to 50 minute mark so i need to
start filling that in
i guess it it is organic but it starts
with understanding that it's a skeleton
and knowing what the major organs are
usually i would find it hard if i didn't
have a good sense of like okay in
general
if it's this type of story
if it's a like i'm trying to think of
something like very simple
if it's a rom-com right
you know the act two climaxes they're
gonna fall out of
whatever there's gonna be the conflict
between the two main leads right and
they're gonna split up
like
if i know that and now i know these
characters and i have a good sense
because i have a sort of general sense
of the story
that like they need to be here at that
moment
i can then start filling out the rest of
it
if i know these sort of big moments
i can start figuring out how we got
there
and like and where we needed to start
and then at that point it is kind of
organic and it just sort of goes where
where
you go where the sort of like
inspiration is not exactly right
but like where the material is taking
you
if that makes sense again i think this
is probably what
most people do like actually writing
pages it's just for me
i don't do that on the page i i do all
that work or as much of that work as
possible
before i actually sit down and start
doing pages
because that to me is too confusing to
keep track of
you said you had in your house or
apartment old outlines that were
in a drawer or something why did you
abandon some of those
i think there's all sorts
i mean there's probably all sorts of
reasons that sometimes you like
sometimes you're you're doing the
outline and you realize that there that
this is not going to be a movie
you might love the idea and it might be
an
amazing log line or amazing high concept
and maybe even someone else would know
what to do with it but you don't
right
that to me is also why i feel like
outlining is really important and
helpful for me because it allows me to
like
because again when you start getting
into it really from a from a business
perspective you go like well
i can't spend forever on this to then
find out that this is not going to come
to fruition that it's that it's missing
some fundamental piece that i can't
solve
right
if it's literally like i don't want to
make it too mathematical but if it's
like an equation
but it cannot be solved i would much
rather know that spending a couple weeks
outlining it
than spending
you know
the more traditional way if you're
actually writing everything out spending
months writing something and going like
oh this
i'm not going to get there
right
so i think that there's a very
utilitarian aspect to doing it that way
i think sometimes you're doing something
that you really love but then something
else comes up that you oh i like this
even better and i'd rather spend my time
doing that
me as a person i feel like time is
incredibly valuable
um
i mean it's not just it's just something
i'm very aware of
every everyone should know the time is
incredibly valuable
um and so to me
it's it's a lot of like well what do i
want to be spending my time doing and is
this time well spent and if there's ways
to expedite
expedite certain aspects of the creative
process because the creative process
it does not fit into a box right the
reality is is that like
even when it is a profession or a career
it still is a little unwieldy
but again outside of
outside of wes anderson
and like you know fall top like pt
anderson like most people like don't
have as much
latitude to follow wherever uh the
creativity takes them
in that moment
um i really hope everybody like
gets there but i feel and
but i feel like for everyone else
i do think it's important to go
how do i try to contain this
how do i try to put this
into a manageable sort of situation
so that i can keep going
and i can
yeah so i can basically like so i can
keep going with it
how long are your outlines and do you do
the 24 plot points
how do you flush this out
so
outlines to me
can be as long or as short as like
as needed as long as they're
as long as they're an effective guide
to like
keep me on track
um
i feel like
when i say an effective guide to keep me
on track i do feel like i want to know
going in
um
if i know what every scene is or
close right like again it's very hard to
get exactly
but like i i forget
i kind of calculate
scenes by script length
so
and i forget exactly what that is i want
to say it's around it's normally around
like
scenes for like uh
for like a hundred
pages 110 pages
again it
these
they're all starting off points right
if i get if i know
if i get to like ah 30 something i go
okay i know i have enough of the
basic building blocks of material here
that i can now start actually
writing
and then again as you're doing it
new scenes scenes go away scenes change
completely
all of that
um
to me it's
it's how do i create an effective
roadmap for myself
to ensure that when this is done there
will be a movie and that movie will
be telling the story that i set out
to tell
or something
close
um
and so again to me that's like
you can then at that point if you if you
know what all the scenes like are or a
good
chunk of that material is
you can like communicate that to
yourself with bullet points with
sentences with whole pages
like
and then i guess usually for me
it's just kind of all over the place
if you're doing it again because you're
trying to
communicate to somebody else i think
that that is different right like when
i'm pitching something and it's like
okay like i need to
this outline needs to communicate to
somebody else so it needs to be fairly
um
in depth right uh but for me
it it just is again it's just
knowing what material
interests me
and they'll keep me on track so it'll be
like some scenes are just bullet points
about what happens in the scene some
scenes are there's huge chunks of
dialogue that i think are happening in
it
sometimes it's the sentence sometimes
it's a paragraph
because to me in that situation all i
need to do is communicate to myself
what is like important for me to
remember
um
which again i just think that that is
then different if it needs to be
communicated to somebody else
and then at that point i would say
probably the more thorough you are
the better i will say in other
professional um
situations
you will save like
learning and being okay with outlining
will save yourself a lot of
grief i think
because often times when you're going
into a situation with other people and
you do need to communicate it to them
like
you need to be able to
show them what you're going to do
right before you do it and this is
something that'll happen a lot like
they'll they'll ask for this because
everybody's working on developing it
together
um
so i think that regardless it's a
it's a good habit to get into
to be okay
outlining and seeing that as a valuable
process because i think it is for many
reasons